se intensifican los combates en el este
de ucrania el kremlin está atacando con
dureza sectores residenciales en jarquín
ubicado a cerca de las líneas de
suministro de las fuerzas rusas que
avanzan sobre la región separatista del
donbass la intensidad del fuego de las
tropas rusas en la dirección de jarque
bombas y la región de dnipropetrovsk ha
aumentado significativamente
intensificó la situación y mariupol
sigue siendo la más difícil posible sin
ningún cambio las tropas rusas bloquean
cualquier intento de organizar
corredores humanitarios salvar a la
gente a nuestra gente a los residentes
locales que están en manos de los
ocupantes
este martes moscú ofreció aquí es un
nuevo ultimátum de alto el fuego para
que las tropas ucranianas que todavía
resisten en la sitiada mariupol depongan
las armas y se rindan el mandatario
ucraniano señaló por su parte que sus
fuerzas lucharán hasta el final los
residentes que sobreviven en los
refugios subterráneos piden que se
respeten los corredores humanitarios
para evacuar la ciudad
quiero que todos los que estén viendo
este vídeo nos ayuden a organizar un
corredor humanitario para que podamos
salir de este lugar a salvo y vivos
tanto civiles como militares todos
jokin luego de una reunión virtual de
los líderes occidentales que apoyan a
volvió de mir selenski hospi diada por
el presidente joe biden la casa blanca
anunció el envío de un nuevo paquete de
ayuda militar tienes 800 millones de
dólares a ucrania
esta mañana me reunió con aliados y
socios para hablar de nuestro apoyo a
ucrania frente a la agresión rusa nos
hemos comprometido a seguir prestando
asistencia y en poner graves costes
económicos a rusia y hemos reafirmado
nuestra solidaridad con el pueblo
ucraniano durante la reunión los líderes
discutieron a aumentar la presión sobre
el kremlin con más acciones y con un
mayor aislamiento diplomático algo que
todavía no ha frenado los brutales
ataques de moscú